These two alternative hypotheses are one-tailed tests. If our sample mean lies
out here in the critical region, significantly higher than the current
population mean, then we're guessing that the population parameter after the
intervention will be greater than the current. Similarly, if our sample mean
lies in the critical region below the current population parameter, the
population parameter with the intervention will have a lower score than it does
currently. And finally, if our sample mean lies in the critical region either
higher or lower than the current population parameter, then we conclude that
the new population will be significantly different. We choose a one-tailed, or
directional hypothesis test when we predict a direction of the treatment
effect. For example, when we predict that a song illustrating the concepts in
this lesson, will increase or decrease engagement. Alternatively, we would
choose a two-tailed, or non-directional hypothesis test, when we do not predict
a direction of the treatment effect. In general we use two-tailed tests because
they are more conservative. We are less likely to reject the null when it's
true. We'll get more into that later. But also because, as you saw before, we
might be wrong about the direction. We might predict that the treatment's going
to increase engagement, when in fact it decreases engagement, in which case we
should have a two-tailed test. If we just use the one-tailed test in the
positive direction, we may miss the fact that the treatment is doing the
opposite of what we would expect. One exception to this general rule is when
we're comparing a new treatment with an established treatment. In such cases,
we often only care if the new treatment is better than the old one. We don't
care if the new one is much worse. So that's when we would use a one-tailed
directional test.